Commission on malaria a true all over
rust Ultima minista
CUDA Sabrina Poland's political
philosophy arose as to our embrace
medicine for any country kites
information oh go go Quahog anaconda
September you are not Palomas finish the
convenient cyst karate Pramila cos
astronaut mother Aminah taught to music
talk to mr. data between de pere milà
say no militia say a to lava Kusa least
youth with heroic music stole apparent
enrich the valleys communique Tony in
Foley comes a key roost Ning hosted
Commission in angle on a lot sky soloist
always dynamic secretary test report
projects stability earned seven Toyota
no another Sam Adams Ellen thought miss
Nascimento miss Ellen anomic anomic a
screech lisa.marta secretary test air
the littoral mostella export the tour
Goodell there was a particular focus on
the skim milk powder stock situation and
America so negotiations
these measures raised by a number of
delegations were principally by France
and supported by a number of member
states
I have also assured the council that the
Commission is prepared to consider all
reasonable options for the disposal of
the existing stock being mindful all the
time not to negatively impact farmgate
prices but also the useful discussion
and the role of agriculture towards the
achievement of the United Nations
sustainable development goals I have
long been of the view that farmers
should be seen as part of the solution
rather than part of the problem in order
to achieve the SDGs and indeed the
climate challenge